so recently I had a question that
someone wanted to know is it okay to do
Kido and in a minute fasting if you have
a heart condition okay and this is a big
fat yes in fact you're gonna get a heart
condition if you don't do Kido in a
minute fasting if you do the typical
high carbs you're gonna get a heart
problem let's talk about why because in
the chain of events that occurs before
you get a buildup of cholesterol
there's always damage to the epithelial
lining on the inside of the arteries
okay and what damages that is high blood
sugar and high insulin okay so those two
things will damage the wall
the cholesterol comes in as a band-aid
same thing with the calcium in the
protein fibrin it comes in there to help
heal it so it's not the bad guy it's
just there to heal it and of course the
person because they're consuming too
many carbohydrates they're gonna have
high cholesterol because those turning
to sugar and then sugar is converted to
high cholesterol okay but that's okay
because you can take a drug for that and
lower it it's called a statin but the
problem with statins is it causes
insulin resistance and more insulin so
it keeps feeding itself but then what
happens the arteries get stiff and the
calcium builds up and then of course you
don't have the elasticity so there goes
the blood pressure so now we have high
blood pressure okay but that's okay we
have a diuretic we can put you on well
the problem with the diuretics is they
deplete potassium also they will
increase insulin and cause insulin
resistance as well so it feeds itself as
well and if you don't have enough
potassium it's going to be really hard
to fix this blood sugar problem because
people with high blood sugars and
insulin resistance always have a
potassium deficiency in the first place
and by taking potassium you can actually
improve that condition and stabilize the
blood sugars a lot better and the blood
sugar and insulin problem will also
cause high blood pressure because it's
been the hardened arteries make the
arteries very inelastic so there's no
expansion but no problem because we have
we can put you in a diuretic okay to
reduce the blood volume and the pressure
should come down because it increases
your risk for insulin resistant
so therefore causing more insulin and
propelling the problem further and also
creates a deficiency of potassium which
you need to actually fix insulin
resistance okay and if it's gonna pull
up potassium guess what you're going to
retain salt so there goes the pressure
as well now if you have arrhythmia as
for example that's usually a potassium
or a magnesium or an electrolyte
deficiency and of course if you have a
heart problem you usually have insulin
resistance which means you can't absorb
potassium that well okay that's one of
the functions of insulin is to help you
absorb these minerals and this
complicates and worsens this problem
right here so you can see that being on
a keto a healthy keto diet with a lot of
vegetables it's very important and
intimate fasting that can drop insulin
and help heal it the combination is very
powerful to heal the situation so you
can eventually come off of these with
the help of your doc okay all right
thanks for watching hey before you go
definitely sign up for my free keto
course I put a link down below it's on
messenger in Facebook but it will give
you all the basics it's very quick it's
like three or four videos and it's free
check it out